Here we're practicing the pattern for collecting values in a class. Here's is
already the instance variable that does the collecting. Before we forget, let's
make sure it's initialize in the constructor, here we go. By the way, I did
forget that when I prepared the solution. Let's see here, here we need to add a
strain to the collection, here's the code for that. Now sometimes, the code
really is as simple as this. It's still necessary to have a separate method
because of course passengers is a private instance variable that the public
can't use. In our example, the add passenger method is a bit more complex
because we should only add when there's space. Last time around we had a
counter for the number of passengers. We don't have that this time, but we have
a method, down here. So I'll just call that method. And again if there's room,
then I'll do the adding. I don't expect that we actually have to implement that
method, that's simply the size of the collection. The last method here, gives
us more information about the contents of our collection. Unfortunately it's
already been implemented. It simply returns the array list converted to a
string, which, has this characteristic form. All of the strings inside,
surrounded by brackets. So that's the general collection pattern, any time that
an object wants to collect other objects. Using the array list or an array such
as this one, and did I mentioned, that you should never forget initialize the
array list or array in the construction. You will get to practice these
patterns with another example that's dear to Sarah's heart.